So, now let's get started. Running code in the Python interpreter.
For this class you don't need to install any new software. You
can run Python right in your web browser, and you should
see something like this in your web browser once the video stops.
There are two parts to this, there's the environment where you
can edit code, so let's type code to print 3. So print
is a Python command that prints something out, and then after
the print, we can have any expression that we want that is
valid Python, and we'll talk more about what expressions are
in Python. Now we're just going to print the number 3,
and when we click Run, it will run this code
and show us the result down here. And the result of
printing 3, we see the output 3. We can do
more interesting things. So, we can print an arithmetic expression, so
I've got 1 plus 1. Now we run this. We
see both outputs, so first we printed 3, we see the
3 here. Then we printed 1 plus 1. We see
the result of 1 plus 1 is 2. We can write
this more clearly by having spaces. We can have spaces
between the parts of our expressions. So we can have one
plus one with spaces between there. that's a little easier
to read, when we run that, we see the same result.
The result is still 2. And we can make more and
more complex expressions, so let's print to result of 52 times
3 plus 12 times 9. This will print out the result of multiplying
52 times 3, and adding that to multiplying 12 times 9, and we get 264.
You can check that yourself to see that Python got the right answer. We can use
parentheses to group expressions. So, if we use parentheses, we can do what
we did before, but putting parentheses around grouping
the multiplications and grouping the other multiplication. And we
run this, we see the same result without the
parentheses, that means the same thing as we had
when we add the parentheses like this. If
we put the parenthesis in different places it means
something different. Now what it means is 52 times
the result of adding 3 plus 12 which is
15 times 9. And so we get the result 7020. So we can combine any expressions
that we want like this. For example if we wanted to compute the number of
seconds in a year, we can compose many
multiplications. So we'll multiply 365 days times 24
hours in a day times 60 minutes in an hour times 60 seconds in a minute.
We can do all those multiplications together and we get
this result. Which is about 31 and a half million
seconds in a year. So now it's time for your
first programming quiz. You've seen enough to be able to write
a Python program. And your goal is to write a
Python program that prints out the number of minutes there are
in seven weeks, which is the amount of time we
have for this course. You'll do that by entering your code
in here. And then you can try different things.
You can try running the code. See the result.
And then when you've got an answer, you can
click to submit that answer and see if it's correct.